We don’t anymore nowadays much believe in
Luck – or what was, in earlier ages, known
as Fortune. We would think it extremely suspicious
if someone explained that they had been sacked,
but added that this was simply the result
of ‘bad luck’. And we would think it equally
strange if someone said they had made a fortune,
but ascribed their triumph to mere ‘good
luck’. We resist the notion that luck can
play a significant role as much in our failures
as in our successes. Luck is a substantial
offence against modern ideals of control,
strategy and foresight. We understand ourselves
to be – for better and for worse – the
authors of our own destinies. Modern civilisation
itself could be viewed as a gigantic protest
against the role of chance in human affairs.
Science, insurance, medicine and public education
take up arms against luck, and have won enormous
battles against it, so many in fact, that
it has grown devilishly tempting to believe
that we may have vanquished it altogether.
However, luck is a fearsome enemy; its territory
is fluid and its power unpredictable and tempestuous.
Wisdom requires us to accept that it will
never be entirely tamed. Within every success,
however ardent our efforts, there is sure
to be a substantial degree of luck. And, more
redemptively, within every failure, there
is sure to be much that cannot be ascribed
to our foolishness alone. We make small mistakes
all the time; it is only occasionally that
a modest error turns out to have devastating
consequences. There are some who already believe
too much in luck; who are excessively willing
to assign all the outcomes of their lives
to chance. They need to hear more about responsibility
and the capacity of individuals to transform
their circumstances. But, in many ways, these
passive actors are ever less common in the
modern world. For the rest of us, those who
operate with a daunting feeling of personal
responsibility, who will constantly push themselves
to match their highest expectations and berate
themselves for failure, a reverential belief
in luck should be far more than a historical
curiosity. It remains a crucial concept to
take the edge off our arrogance and, when
fate has turned against us, to temper the
violence of our self-hatred.
Our Wisdom Display Cards eplore what it really means to be wise
and how we can strive to become more enlightened in our everyday lives.  Be sure to subscribe to our channel and turn on notifications.